From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
It is the 27th of June 2016 today and we are here in Los Angeles, California.
This is David Cline from the History Department at Virginia Tech and working with the Civil Rights History Project
of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian's National Museum of African American History and Culture.
We have with us John Huggins Bishop of Media Generation behind the camera also Guha Shankar of the Library of Congress is here with us.
And we are so honored to be here with Norma Mtume.
And if I could ask you is the one time I will coach you at all to introduce yourself with a full sentence, my name is, or I am, and where you are born and what year?
Okay, I am Norma Mtume currently. I was born in 1949 in San Diego, California, Norma Stoker.
And later I married so my name was Norma Armore. At the time I was in the Black Panther Party my name was Norma Armore.
So I just, historical purposes for my children, my grandchildren, I wanted to make sure that those names were on file.
Thank you.
And can you tell me about the adoption of M. Tume?
Well, I married in M. Tume who changed his name in the 60s as a lot of us were doing. We didn't want our slave names anymore.
And so he chose M. Tume. His name is Omawale Mtume and it means the sun returns. And it's Kiswahili and Nigerian.
It's powerful.
Yeah.
So wonderful. And if you could tell, let's start with your childhood or even before your parents and tell me a little bit about your...
All right. My mother was Doris Sims. She was from born in Louisiana but raised in Arkansas and Louisiana.
Came to California during the World War II, moved to the layhold where, you know, folks were going to where they could work in the war industry.
My dad was born in Longview, Texas. He went to the military and after he got out, he moved to San Diego. He became a librarian of all things.
And I lived in San Diego until I was about four. Then moved to Los Angeles with my mom, my folks split up.
So I've been in Los Angeles area most of my life. I moved away when I was in the party for a few years. I moved up North.
Came back home to Roost and pretty much been here since.
Kisni, I wonder if you could tell me a little bit about the racial geography of Los Angeles during those years.
And if that shapes you at all.
It did. And I tell you my first experience, even thinking about me being in the skin really a lot.
Where I lived in Los Angeles, it was primarily after Americans or Negroes or Colors or Blacks, as we became over the years.
And very few Latinos who were pretty much all Mexican.
One or two Asian, as you came further west, we had more Japanese, went further north, more Korean.
But where I lived, it was mainly Black people.
Very poor neighborhood. I grew up in South Central around 21st and Naomi for those of you who know Los Angeles.
And almost everybody came to school with cardboard and the shoes when they started wearing out.
I mean, it was no, you didn't think of yourself as super poor until you were able to get out of that environment and see what other people had.
Because the other people around you, they pretty much had what you didn't have, what you didn't have, rather.
When I was in high school in the mid-60s, started to become a little bit more conscious about what's going on there, what's going on around the world.
Some of our older brothers and neighbors and friends, and as we got to be seniors, some of our boyfriends were drafted, went to Vietnam.
I think that opened a lot of folks eyes.
Especially when we saw the guys, the ones that made it back, they didn't come back quite the same.
And a lot of them have never been the same since then.
Like I said, very poor. I managed to get a scholarship. $250.
From high school to go to college, you know, go figure. That would buy about book and a half these days.
So I went to Jefferson High School, which was basically all black.
We had two Caucasians, two brothers that I remember the Crab Whales, I remember because they only wasn't this whole school.
But that's kind of what the neighborhood was like. We were poor.
And then when riots started, when people started really, really feeling like enough is enough, we really don't have what we need to survive.
Folks got angry and they started doing what they thought they needed to do to get some attention.
What year did you graduate high school?
I graduated in 1967. In 1967.
Yeah, so it was just after we had the big watts uprising. After I graduated I went to Cal State LA.
And we had a very active black student union there.
Had you done anything in high school? Were there any organizations yet?
I didn't. I was too busy trying to pull myself up by my bootstraps. Not knowing at the time that I really didn't have any boots to put straps in.
I was going to college. I was going to be a math and PE teacher, majoring in math and minor in PE.
Then I started meeting some of the students on campus who were active in the DSU.
And I met my first husband, Albert Armour. He was very active in the black student union and later became a black Panther Party member.
And that's how I got involved with the Panthers. Because I really wasn't involved in very much before then.
Are you able to go back and try to remember the first time that you became aware of the Panthers and trying to figure out what the Audiology was and what this was about?
I know he had Panthers stickers on his car. He had a little blue VW bug and when he would come to the house.
And then he would have a Muhammad Speaks newspaper with him. So he was just, oh, he was getting information from everywhere.
He would come to the house and my mother would just be really, really upset. She didn't want him coming over anymore with that black Panther and that black Muslim stuff.
He took me to an anti-war protest rally, the big one that was out in Westwood.
And I believe it was in late 67 or summer 67.
And it just erupted and they started beating heads and stuff. And I'm standing around looking. I've never been exposed to anything like this before.
So find you that they're dragging me. Come on, we got to get out of here. So I was actually there at that rally and that was my first time saying, you know, this really isn't.
Right, I didn't watch a whole lot of TV. I was always into the books and reading and I didn't have time. So I saw that.
That was early 67 and my husband became a full fledged member of the party. He dropped out of college. I was still going to school.
He kept trying to get me to come around and do things. But I just, you know, I didn't have time for that. I had another avenue that I was going to take.
But in December 69, when the police raided all the party offices here, he was in one of the offices and they beat him up pretty badly.
He was in the hospital for a while. I broke his arm, damaged one of his eye sockets pretty badly.
And then that got my attention that that woke me up. And that was in December.
And by January, I was volunteering at the local office on 44th Street.
What was left of it, you know, we still were trying to function out of there. I started doing typing for the officer of the day, type memos, form and whatnot.
And then I worked in the breakfast program. And the clinic was starting here. And I always had an interest in the body and in health.
I guess that's why I liked physical education. Other than it was just fun. I like to play.
And so I was assigned to work at the clinic and I became the coordinator, the person who ran the clinic.
That was some experience. I was 19 years old.
It's amazing how young everyone.
Yes.
And what you were all took on.
Yeah, yeah. But I had a lot of help from there were a lot of professionals who were willing to lend their time and talents and skills.
Marie F. Branch was an RN and she taught at University of California, Los Angeles. And Dr. Terry Kupers was a psychiatrist.
And they helped us to get residents and doctors to volunteer and nursing students and nurses to come and volunteer at the clinic.
And we didn't have any paid staff there. And that's how it went.
These are all African American health professionals. No. No. Marie F. Branch is African American. Dr. Cooper's is white.
But we had an assortment of, you know, it was a real good mixture of a diversity that we had there.
Can I ask you since we're on that about other sort of coalitions that formed at that time, partners that you worked with?
There were the nurse, the student nurses, health educators. Some of the doctors who were really liberals, they had their associations that they were with.
But I was just really, really focused on running the clinic. And that was a full time job because besides caring for the community, we had to care for the party members.
And now I'm doing work with a Charles R. Charles R. Charles R. Drew University of Medicine and Science. And looking at health disparities and, you know, we're the sickest people in the world.
The community that I come from, we have, we're the sickest people in this country.
And a lot of our illnesses compare real closely to what's going on in some third world countries, in terms of our birth rate, still birth rates, low birth rate, children.
And miscarriages and things like that. But I'm just saying that to say that I didn't really have time to do a whole lot of the things that was focused on running the clinic and the health of the party members.
And the people that we serve at the clinic and that that was more than a full time job.
So let's start from the beginning because you're 19 years old. You've had a year of college at this point or so. Yeah.
And are assigned this task.
It was a lot of self-study.
Has the clinic opened yet?
I was there to clinic open. They had a Dicks opening day.
And then you were told you'll be running this.
Yeah.
And what happened?
You just get it in gear. You do a lot of self-study. You do a lot of reading.
And I said I had a lot of mentors from, especially from Marie F. Branch, who was the nurse and the nursing instructor.
She gave me things to read. She just taught me, I mean, she taught me how to eat yogurt.
I didn't even know what yogurt was. I'd never had yogurt when I was 19 years old. I wasn't what we ate.
You know, various uses for it. And a lot of natural healing practices we discussed as well.
I don't know. It was just you learned. You got books. You found people. We didn't have an internet.
So you had to hustle and get that information and the best that you could.
And it just, I learned a lot in a little bit of time.
Can you describe the physical place of the clinic?
It was a storefront. We had a lab tech student who father was a construction contractor.
So he had been working with his father for a long time. He came in and built the lab out for us.
And we were able to put up petitions so that we could have different operating rooms.
So he built out the lab and he built us a pharmacy area.
We worked with the farm. That was one of the things that the doctors did was to work with the pharmaceutical reps who came to their place and asked them to give us samples.
So that was where we got most of our medication so that we could give it to the folks who came to the clinic for free.
So we got it built out. I'm not a good judge, a square footage.
But we had three exam rooms, a little reception area, an area for the pharmacy in the lab here in Los Angeles.
And what was the location?
It was at 30 second and central.
And it was completely free.
Well, we had to pay rent for the building.
And everything was free. We didn't charge for anything. People could get donations when they came in.
But all care was free.
So did it take some outreach to let people know that you were there and that they weren't strings attached?
Yes, yes. And we did that outreach in the community. But when folks came out to sell papers as well, you know, there was information about the clinic.
And there were articles in our newspaper about the various clinics around the country.
And we collected donations on the street for the clinic too. So folks got to learn about the clinic that way.
Do you remember any of the sort of the why we're going to do a clinic, the justification or the ideology that said that this is important?
Yes, it was one of the points of our 10 point platformer program.
I think it's number four. We want decent health care. We want health care that, you know, keeps us healthy to start with, but gets us well when we get sick.
And so we were just carrying out our platform that we said the reason that we existed.
We knew that we had substandard housing, education, health care.
We were the most that got beat up by the police. We were going to prison more than anybody else.
So those were the things that we really were stepped out to address.
Well, I'll come back to the clinic, but I want to sort of ask about daily life of a young woman in the LH after the Panthers.
What was it like? What was the what was daily life?
I think that the young woman with a two-year-old child, well, let's see, maybe he was a year and a half.
And when I finally, after my husband got out of the hospital and I started coming around more, eventually I gave up my apartment and I just moved into the party facilities as well, me and my son.
Shortly after, I got pregnant with my daughter. That's Albert, our more the third in LH are more.
And so, when we went in the party, there were a lot of women just like me. They had children.
So we had to make provisions so that the children could be safe and care for. So we had a nursery for the children because we worked long, long hours.
We would be up in the morning in order, you know, 536 in order to get ready for the breakfast program.
So we'd get the kids fed and then folks would go off to their various work assignments.
I would go to the clinic, other folks would go to the field, other people might be working in the office where we put together our flyers, our posters.
A couple of the few of the main writers for the newspaper were from the Los Angeles chapter, so they would go to Oakland for a few days a week to work on the newspaper.
So the children had to be taken care of it, so that was first informal. So we made sure that we put that in place.
So you'd go out, strike out to the clinic about 930 or 10. You worked there to like six or so.
And we often had evening clinics as well because the regular people, they have to go to work.
And so they can't take our work and say lose money. So we had lots of evening clinics.
And that's how we were able to get a number of our doctors to volunteer as well because once they got off work, they could come and volunteer their time at night.
So there were days when you may be at the clinic to 10, 10 or 11, you know, cleaning up and getting ready for the next day.
Then if you got back to the centers early enough, you ate dinner, you had political education class maybe.
And if you were on guard duty because everybody had to have a guard shift, we didn't want what was happened to Fred Hampton to happen to us.
You just didn't know. Somebody had to be watching all the time.
So we would come back from our daily assignments. And if we didn't do political education class or have some other kind of meeting or a rally or something that we needed to go to, you were lucky you might get in the bed by 12.
11 or 12. I get a couple hours sleep and you get up for your couple hours of duty to on security watch and go back to sleep and you get up and you do it all over again.
So the work ethic that we got, as such a young age, how we learned how to work like that. Nobody can outwork us these days.
And later when you go into a regular job, they just can't do it. They're not used to that kind of work.
And not saying that that's something that you should try to sustain for a lifetime.
Because it's really hard and it's wearing on your body over time. But that's what we felt that we needed to do and that's what we did.
You mentioned Fred Hampton and can you talk a little bit more about the harassment and fear and intimidation and targeting that you all experienced?
Yes, we had, we were harassed and targeted by the police but other groups that we had different ideological perspectives.
One example was one day and we did this. Everything was communal.
The laundry, everything got you. If you were assigned to do laundry, you might have four or five people's and their family, the kids laundry to do.
So my girlfriend and I were going to do laundry one evening. And as soon as we pulled out of the parking spot, they're the police.
So they just stayed right there and waited for you to drive off so that they could stop you and harass you for some petty traffic infraction that they say that you might have committed.
And so we're sitting there and one police goes to his car and then he comes back and he's got this whole portfolio of photos.
He starts asking me these people's names, people that are in the party. And then he had my license so he knew my name so he first he pulled up my husband's picture and said, who was that?
I said, oh that's my brother. So I think for the longest, without them doing any deep check and they thought that we were brother and sister eventually I think they caught on.
But I mean, every time you left, you would look to see if there was a patrol car or an unmarked car on the street.
And I think the women got off a little bit easier sometime than the guys. The guys, they just knew as soon as they walked out the gate with their papers under their arm. They were going to get harassed and they were going to get arrested.
They were going to be a beat or whatever. So it was constant. And at night, especially after the raids on the various offices and all, you just, you didn't know if your number was up next.
But if you have that commitment, you stayed. People that didn't. I want to do something else with my life. I don't want to give it up this way.
Then they leave. So people came and they went. Some people stayed longer than others.
Did you have strategies for coping?
Drink it and drug it.
This might be one of the things I tell you to take out.
But no, I mean, you know, when we had a chance to cool down, if we had, we might have a party or a birthday party or something.
It is high, high stress. It's a wonder some of us didn't stroke out or something.
No, I mean, I recognized early on that there were a lot of folks who had alcohol problems. Later on, started using different types of drugs.
But then we have to remember that these are people that came in from the community. People that joined the party, they were all doing those kinds of things.
When they came into the party, they were ready to clean up. Because it wasn't allowed. You couldn't be a drug head and alcoholic it every day and do the work that you needed to do.
So that wasn't condoned. But because we were who we were, you know, we some of us slipped back into those habits.
But no, there were, there were, we had a psychiatrist who worked with us.
Like I said, Dr. Cooper's was a psychiatrist in up north. We had a Dr. Shapiro, I think his name was.
And every now and then, you know, somebody would really, you know, kind of go out there.
But for every day, having mental health services or therapy or support groups and that kind of stuff, other than just commiserating among yourselves, nothing I can recall.
What about the being a woman in the party? And I know that numerically, I think, right, sisters made up the majority at certain points.
It wasn't the easiest thing. I mean, we, based on principles, we tried to make all things equal, you know, that women could do what men could do.
And the men, you know, the men cooked the men clean, that there were men assigned to the children's centers and whatnot.
But like I said, the people that were in the party were people who were not in the party and came into the party.
So they brought those same behaviors and, you know, some chauvinism that not just men in our community, but all over the world, the patriarchal societies.
So that was something that you, you know, constantly had to deal with.
I would think that points and was a little bit alleviated, little bit more alleviated, because eventually more and more women became, came into the leadership positions.
And it was something we had to deal with.
Is there a special bond now among the veteran Panther women?
Oh yes, yes, yes, they are there. And it's like you were in high school and you have four or five people that you bond with them.
You don't bond with the whole class, but there are four or five of us who are, you know, still talk and commit a raid about things that are going on now and reflect on things that were going on then.
And well, a couple of us were having this discussion about how our work ethic and how, you know, we served the people body and soul was, you know, one of our slogans.
And after a while, especially when you get closer to my age, you just have to start to pull that back and say, wait, I got to take better care of myself.
I can't give all of your way every day all day anymore. I really got to reel that back and now spend more time with my grandkids and my children.
And just, yeah, we do. We have a good bond. And it's those kind of friends that probably that some people will never make in life.
These are people that you trusted your life with for real.
How did you go back a little bit for a second, but you talked about your parents' initial reaction to your boyfriend who would later become your husband. How did they handle your involvement in the park?
My mother, well, we had a free busing the prisons program. And my oldest brother was in San Quentin.
We were here in Los Angeles, some of my mother had never been able to go and see him.
So when we had a bus trip that was going up to San Quentin, I got my mom signed up and she and I went to visit my brother in San Quentin.
And she, before that, and after that, she never went after that. It was, it was no problem. But what we were doing in the party was all right. She got an idea to, and over time, she got an idea to see some of the things that we were doing.
So she was okay with it. And my father, I think he was just more afraid for my safety. He came to accept it after point two.
My first experience with discrimination that I can recall. My father used to take my brother and I to Texas every year.
And we would drive. And normally he lived in San Diego. We would stop in El Paso for halfway. And we would get a motel. Of course, that was like in 55, 56. So it was a black motel. You would stay at.
And then you would get up the next morning and get you some breakfast and drive on.
I think it's called The Negro Motorist Green Book that listed African American owned motels.
I don't know. My dad just knew because he, you know, being from Texas and going back and forth all the time. Yeah.
But this one particular time we were going, I was about nine years old. We got to El Paso. And the black Baptist convention was going on. So all the black motels were taken out.
So we had, there was no room at the end. So my dad said, I got a stop and get some sleep. So he said, I'm just going to pull over on the side of the road here. You know, we'll get a couple hours of sleep. He pulls underneath some willow trees. Well, you know how the willow trees are going.
I said, Daddy, I can't sleep. The trees are calling me. And I kept on it. Finally, he just got up and started driving. Well, it was morning. He said, I need to get some coffee.
And we need to get something to eat. Well, there everything still said no color. It's allowed and you know, whites only in black water, I mean, color water, white water.
So my dad, he said, we got a stop. He put up to the restaurant and my stepmom was saying, oh, no, Calvin, you can't go in there. You can't go in the air. He said, no, he's from Texas. He knows how to handle it. So he goes around to the back door.
And about 15 minutes, he comes back and he's got coffee and donuts and food. And so he says, I mean, that's what you have to do. You know, you just have to suck it up. You know, you and your family have to eat.
You just go and do what they tell you to do. And you come out and we get in the car and we drive on. I'll never forget that as long as I live out. That was my first introduction to, you know, I really am treated differently than other people.
Do you remember what your thoughts were and their young mind just right at that moment? Yeah. And I was wondering, you know, why why is dad have to go in the back?
And then when we actually got to my grandmother's house that year, we're passing this beautiful park with a nice woman who said, oh, and you know, Texas is humid. It's like July.
And we can go swimming there. Dad says, no, you can't swim there. But there's a black pool down the street. And we pass this beautiful high school. I said, oh, dad, is that where you went? He says, no, we go down the street.
And you can the stark differences in that park and the other park. But the thing that really got me as we were going to go to the drive in one night. So we get to the drive in movie.
We have to go all the way in the back. The black people had to sit so far back that they had bleachers. You had to get out of your car to see the screen.
I mean, all of that in one trip. And so that that's really imprinted in my mind. I never forget that. I'll look for you about.
But not later.
And that was without having a big influence.
Yeah.
And later on, you start to reflect back on that. But when I get back to my own community, it's the same. So you don't really think about it that much anymore.
Do you get older and start getting a little bit more consciousness about, well, there's a whole bunch of this stuff going on all the time.
And we need to do something about it.
What were some of the other survival programs that the party had in place?
I'm going to send it away.
We had a food program where we gave away free bags of food.
Rosu is to folks who were in need. This is kind of pre-food bank type of situations.
We had a free clothing program, free coats program and the winter, especially in those places like Chicago and New York.
We got really, really cold to imagine kids having to go to school and they don't have coats to wear.
What else do we have? We had so many. We had a seniors program.
Seniors against the feel for an environment, it was called safe, where we would escort seniors to the bank, into the grocery store, to doctor's appointments.
In the clinics that we had outreach programs, we would actually go out into the community and do some services.
That was kind of novel.
I think we learned that from watching what they were doing in Cuba and in China.
The barefoot doctors who went out to the community to work with people to keep them well and to get them well.
Gosh, I have a whole book of what our programs were.
A legal program where we help folks who need it to find attorneys pro bono or lower rates.
We actually had people in the party who essentially were paralegals. They helped prepare for the upcoming cases and whatnot.
We had free educational programs. We had a school which was so proud of in Oakland.
Before you went to school, you went to the nursery. I'm sure that Ericka Huggins will talk a lot about that.
As soon as his mom was well enough, after having the baby and strong enough, we would not have the baby go to the nursery.
Folks who were assigned to work there, they were like assigned there 24 hour on duty for the nursery.
The shifts changed week to week or however they had it set up.
But in the same with the school, when you were two and a half or so, you were potty trained and you went to the school and you started your formal education.
You go to school the day time and at night you go to the dormitory and folks who are assigned to be there.
That really freed us up to continue to work these long crazy hours.
This is how your kids pick up on Monday morning with their little bags, the van we pick them up.
They'd be at school all week and they'd drop them off on Friday night.
They're little dirty clothes and you'd clean them all up and put them back on the van on Monday.
I mean you could go and see them during the week, you know, you had time to drop in but that's it.
And they were static, they were in heaven, they were treated like little queens and kings so it was fine with them.
The hardships, some of my comrades now would tell me how angry their children were, my kids were especially my oldest boy when we left.
They were really upset that we left and we had to leave the school.
So I was like they're little hay then.
And so advanced, when they came out I was able to put them ahead of, a great ahead of where the schools wanted to put them.
I brought them to Los Angeles and they wanted to put them in school according to their ages and I said no, they're going to be bored in there.
So I took them to San Diego and they put them in a grade that I asked them to put them in and they've all done well.
The clinic here, what was the name of the clinic?
It was the, I'll print this Alprentice "Bunchy" Carter people's Greek clinic.
And can you tell us who Alprentice "Bunchy" Carter was?
Alprentice "Bunchy" Carter.
Yeah, Alprentice "Bunchy" Carter is the person whom he and John Huggins, as they started the Los Angeles chapter.
So in his honor and commemorating him, we named the clinic after him.
And I had the opportunity to go to a luncheon that was helpful for his mother about two months ago.
And she was like a freedom fighter from way back so I could see where he got his desire and understanding about equal justice for folks that were disenfranchised and had so many unmet needs.
His mother just, she worked in programs in starting and running civil rights type issues based programs here in Los Angeles for a long time.
A long time, yeah.
Did you ever meet him or was it?
I met, I was able to meet him one time at a rally because that was when I was just, you know, kind of coming around a little bit.
I was trying to get me to formally join and I wouldn't, but I met him at a rally once.
And just this very impressed by the way that he carried himself and the way that he commanded the other guys to do things, and not commanded in a you do this kind of thing, but the way that he, the leadership that I saw shining out through him.
Just that one time that I met him, I was really impressed with that.
And then later on, you know, learning more about him and then reading his poetry and whatnot, you get to get a better sense of who the man really was.
What were some of the challenges, I mean, we know the circumstances of his death and different ways in which that story has been told, I suppose.
But what were some of the challenges in terms of relations with other organizations at that time?
Well, there was the, primarily the us organization, Ron Karenga's group.
And my ex-husband, Albert Amor, was at University of California, Los Angeles when he was going to school there when that occurred.
And so, you know, hearing firsthand from him and one of my best friends from high school was in the party and was there at University of California, Los Angeles when that happened.
It just, you know, it puts us our taste in your mouth and in your heart is not right towards that bad group of folks.
Just for the record, can you, can I ask you to describe what, what happened?
My understanding is that an Ericka Huggins can give you a much better account of it because she was her husband was there.
Well, it was killed with bunch of.
There was some difference in ideology about how things should be run in terms of the Black student union and what was happening with the Black students on campus and whatnot.
And, you know, the panthers, our ideology was based on what had happened in some other revolutions.
And so, you know, we Charles R. Charles R. Drew from, you know, from some from the Russian, some from the Chinese and some from what happened in Cuba and tried to, and things that happened in South America and in the islands and tried to put it together and make it work for what we have here.
And dialectical materialism.
In South America, the American organization, they were very affercentrant, you know, referring everything back to Africa.
And that's not something that we did at that time, you know.
And so, just riffs occurred. Even when I was pregnant with my daughter and I was out selling papers one day, I was attacked by people from the US Organization.
And I was a girl with six brothers and they couldn't handle me.
And we were on the street corner so they, you know, they weren't going to try to do too much, but they did try to attack me and I was able to fend them off.
And did those kinds of things happen?
Those kinds of things happen. They would catch one or two people by themselves and, you know, people would beat them up.
And I think that that kind of stuff happened here in San Diego where us and the Panthers were there too.
Because they, I don't think that they were around in all the cities where we had chapters.
But he, I mean, and over time, you know, you, I consider myself to be someone who has some practice forgiveness and heart and whatnot.
And that one with Corangus just really hard because he did some other things after that, you know, he even, what, what did he have as his wife or some other people, other women from the US Organization that he was holding like captive.
And he just, and he never fessed up to what he did.
And he was convicted. And from what I recall, he was convicted. And he's still a big time professor, you know, down in San Diego and running around the country, is tossing his views or whatnot.
And I just, I can't abide.
No, I don't have hatred. I don't have enough room in my heart to be hating anybody.
But he's somebody that I don't ever have as in his presence. And I'm just fine with that.
So gunfire actually erupted that day.
Oh, oh yeah. Yeah.
And, you know, it came to head because I guess these meetings were going on and, you know, harsh words and whatnot happened.
And it's from what we believe, what I believe in a lot of other people, other people have probably had more proof than I do that Corangus gave the order for those guys to shoot, bunching John Huggins.
Because I just, and operating in collaboration with the police probably, but that's another whole issue that, you know, I don't feel like he's really cleared himself up.
And was it not long after that that the office has got rated? Or was that quite a bit later?
Yeah, that was early on in the year.
And I can remember that offices were rated in December, but that occurred earlier in a year.
I'm thinking like February and in the winter.
I remember correctly.
Yeah.
And that, that was before I was actually in the party because I didn't come along to late 69.
So, he was killed before. I came to the party.
But they were killed, weren't you in time?
Yeah.
So do you remember how people reacted?
Like I said, I was not in the party.
You were right, you were not in yet.
But what happened then, you know, it just, the carryover afterwards, it just kind of kept on the sentiments between the Panthers and us organization, got him worse.
And at that time, well, you go out and you would be collecting donations or selling papers.
And there were special corners where you would have more foot traffic and you would probably have more sales and whatnot.
One corner would be Black Panthers.
Another corner would be us organization.
One corner would be the Nation of Islam.
And another corner would be the Holy Ghost Phil Christian.
Where were the Holy Ghost Christians?
They were at the airport mostly.
Yeah, so I mean it was a time.
Yeah, it was a time.
I mean, it was a very interesting period of time in the 60s and 70s just watching all the different ideas and people had about how we should be in this country.
Now we didn't have the gang situation that we had now obviously in LA but the saucents were around.
We had gangs before the party and like I said, the community came into the party and when it came to the party, we weren't gang members anymore.
We had Slausons, the pueblos, the body snatches, we had the Roman 20s, we had a lot of gangs.
But the party attracted a lot of those folks because I mean they were out there, they had the misplaced aggression.
They were mad and upset, they knew something wasn't right but they were taking it out of the wrong folks.
And once they got a little bit of consciousness under their belt, then they saw you know this another way for me to channel my energies.
And no, we didn't have this gang kind of situation here in LA until the party left and then the powers that we bought that dumped all the crack here and the gangs and it's...
Was there any time?
I know this from some of the other chapters where you are bringing in people from the streets who have legitimate reasons to be angry and a lot of it.
And you know when you're trying to be disciplined, right, but things spill out, was there any...
Yeah, you know, people explode, you know, but I mean you try to handle it diplomatically.
And we all know that we all came with a whole bunch of different types of baggage and you just try to deal with it case by case.
You know, so and so is... some of us are not able to go off at any time so don't go talking crazy around it especially today because such it's such happened.
I mean, you know, and over time hopefully some of those temperaments change, you know.
And some of them, they didn't, then they left, but they were asked to leave or kicked out for whatever.
And does that happen?
Yeah, people got kicked out, people got suspended, people left on their own.
So you mentioned earlier, but you so you started with the clinic here and then you got reassigned up North, right?
Yes, well actually here I was working with the finance, I mentioned that a few of the women actually went up North every year, every week to work on the newspaper.
Well the person who was in charge of finances here knew that I was pretty good with math.
And so she became my mentor, she trained me how to handle the finances as well when she was gone.
So I was doing the clinic, but I was also doing the finances.
So that's what I was doing here, both of those.
And then when there was a call for all the chapters to move up North to work in the political campaigns that we were starting, I was assigned to the George Jackson Free Clinic in Berkeley.
And became the director there.
Did you go with the whole family?
Was that when the kids were in school?
Well actually my two year old was already there.
He went when he was about two and a half, maybe close to three.
He was already up at the school.
And my daughter went with me because she was only a few months old when we moved.
So when I went there I became in charge of that clinic and it was operated pretty much the same way.
We had a lot of folks that I collaborate with there though because Berkeley is just the heart of collaboration and unity and getting things done.
We had the Berkeley Free Clinic, we had the Women's Health Collective, Haydashbury Free Clinic sent folks over to teach us about substance abuse.
So that was my first training in drug abuse.
Is that where your dad worked?
My dad and his friends, Haight-Ashbury Free Clinic, we would write around the corner.
Okay, so we get a lot of help from them.
And there was an organization called Community Services United which was a coalition of nonprofits who received funding from Berkeley City.
And we met monthly to, mainly to let each other know what we were doing so that we could avoid duplication of services so that you wanted to go and ask for money, you weren't asked for money that the city was already funding something for.
And so that, yeah, there were a lot of people that we worked with and we worked with UC Berkeley had a group called the Black Health Science Caucus.
These were pre-med students who came and volunteered their time and worked in the labs and worked in the clinic and taught us how to do different lab work.
We were here in Los Angeles but more so in Berkeley, I and some of the other clinic workers were, we were taught a lot about medicine.
We were, I tell folks, we were probably practicing medicine without a license but we had physicians there who were overseeing what we were doing.
We worked with a lot of, Vietnam vets who were corpsmen as well.
So they had a lot of on the ground skills by how do you work with folks in an emergent type situations and whatnot.
So we learned how to draw blood, we learned how to do stitches, we worked on frank voters, we worked on winters to do stitches because the skin is real sensitive and it's like real people skin.
So we did women's exams, we did vaginal exams and I have a very personal experience with that that we would practice on each other and then we would send our labs out.
So mine came back positive for cervical cancer or something irregular.
So we did it again and sent it out again, came back again.
So I went to my gynecologist and sure enough I had to have surgery but that's how I found out that I had cervical cancer and I forget that I'm a cancer survivor these days because I caught it so early.
I just never, never think in terms of being a survivor but I am and that's how I found out.
It's really fun, that's amazing.
So we, the Merck Manual, I mean it just tells you about all the different diseases and illnesses and whatnot.
We just read this stuff, you know like it was a novel or something, we just collected all this information.
Oh hey, I got one of the shelves still. I've given it to all my girls, my daughters, my granddaughters.
Yes, the women's health collective book, yeah we, and we try to teach people to take care of themselves, you know as best they could.
Don't get sick, I mean we have to worry about getting well.
As much as you can, I mean some of it's a red itary, you just have to watch out for those types of things to stay ahead of diabetes and you know watching your sugar, watching your weight and that kind of stuff so we're exercising.
So we were, we were trying to do all that.
Was that part of the party platform too to maintain personal health and...
Well, let's see, what was that one of our, well I should tell people, what, what are those who treat their bodies as, for belonged themselves?
Who was something from a mower or something?
That's why we changed it around a little bit.
But yeah, I, that, folks needed to be well, needed to be well.
And we had a, a community, a community called Disease Control Program too.
We had an outbreak of a, Shagella at one of the, one of the sites.
And we worked with the pediatricians, we had pediatricians from Children's Hospital who came and ran the pediatric clinic for some of the residents came and did that.
And we were taught, you know, that you need to separate them from other people until they're asymptomatic and then they can go back and say everybody's in the middle of a community.
You know, one person gets something and it's spread like wildfire, wildfire.
Same thing with chickenpox, two or three kids in one facility.
You know, everybody was gonna get chickenpox so they were, everybody was just confined there and do.
Bring the ones that hadn't had it yet.
Yeah, let the kids go ahead, let them get it.
And then during the time of, you know, the 60s, free love, you know, free speech, free love, flower children.
I think we probably treated more STIs, STDs at the clinic than we treated a lot, especially in Berkeley than we treated other things.
But we had control in the clinic like that.
It's, we were bringing in folks from all over the country.
So as soon as you got to town, you had to come and get your medical screen.
And you got screened for a gonorrhea, syphilis, committee, you know, whatever.
Did you have a yeast infection?
You got treated. If you had something that someone else could catch by you having sex with them, you were put on a list.
And you were not to have, and that list was published, and you were not to have sex with anyone that was on that list.
This was within the park.
There was no hip-a-laws in the park.
But I mean, that's how you control because it was rapid.
I mean, in Berkeley, there was, in the very, there was just a lot of STDs at that time, because everybody was, you know, free love.
That's why I never heard that before.
So we are in Berkeley.
Yes.
So how long were you all at the, or are you in the office?
I was there.
I was in the Bay Area from 72 to 77.
And I ran a clinic from 72 to about 74.
And that was by the time that Huey P. Newton P. Newton left the party, then Bobby Seale Seale left, and then Elaine Brown Brown became the person in charge.
And she knew that I had the experience, the person who handled the finances here was handling, been handling the finances there.
And she knew that I had the experience from Los Angeles, so she asked me what I'd come and become the Minister of Finance.
So I left the clinic and started handling the headquarters finances.
We were there when Elaine Brown Brown was made president that evening or day when she was announced as the head of the department.
I probably was.
Actually, I was just recovering from surgery, so I may not have been, I was there in the area, but I may not have been at the particular event.
Like I said, I had a relapse.
And so she asked me while I was recovering, would I take over the finances, because that's one of the big shifts in personnel, I guess you call it now.
And so I told her, yes, so right that was like in late 74, I started handling the finances.
So you worked out of headquarters in Oakland, my home.
Yeah, and Oakland headquarters, but yeah, I did a lot of work from where I live as well.
So can you tell me what that was like, especially that transition?
Yeah, well, like I said, I was just handling the finances here, so it was just on a bigger scale there.
I had to make sure that the funds were accounted for when folks came in from getting donations, selling papers, if people gave us donations, to make sure that all the properties were the notes and the rents were paid, utilities, and people had money for food.
And you know, they had the clothing if they didn't have other kinds of income.
But everyone who had some kind of income, this was one of the eat it steady, eat lane came up with everyone who had some kind of income paid a tie, whatever you got, 10% went into the pot for the very survival programs and to maintain the facilities where you lived and whatnot.
So I was responsible for making sure that the money got collected and distributed bills paid properly.
Later we were able to incorporate the school and get grants.
So then I had to learn to be an accountant, to book keeping officially before I was just keeping things in ledgers.
But I had to learn to actually do the accounting records, keep those together and bring them up to the point of trial down to then give them to the CPA to do the 990 tax returns.
And so that was my introduction into the real nonprofit world.
And so I did that from 74 to 77.
And since then I've been doing healthy finance.
So did you, a couple of questions. One is I'm just curious. So you were married.
Was it difficult to maintain a relationship during?
Yes, when I moved to Oakland, my husband was still stationed in Los Angeles.
And I was in Oakland for probably a couple of years.
And yeah, it was just strained. It was strained.
And we never really got back together until we both left the fight.
So you know, we went our separate ways and the kids, I had the kids one weekend and then he'd have them because he did eventually move there.
But he became a stripping with multiple squalsis.
And was, you know, what he could do was limited.
He actually became my assistant in the finance area because he couldn't do a lot of field work.
So we worked together very closely up there.
And even when we weren't living it, it was difficult.
There were a number of folks that came in a couple and I don't know if any of them left that way.
But that's not to say with the high degree of divorce in our community that it wouldn't have happened anyway.
Just...
I'll talk about that later.
So can you tell me the story of leaving the party?
Yes, I will.
Huey P. Newton P. Newton came back from Cuba.
And as you know, things would just start to be so different.
Because when Elaine Brown Brown took over, we started doing more...
What do you say mainstream type of funding we got?
We even had a law enforcement grant to run some of the services that we had this school nonprofit.
Then we had a nonprofit that was like a social service wing that worked with all these other programs that clinic fell under that, the seniors program fell under that clothing.
Food, other programs outside of education fell under that social service wing.
So that we were getting into operating more legitimately as far as other people were concerned.
But it also helped to bring in monies that made our programs sustainable.
And when Huey P. Newton P. Newton came back, you know, things just...
They just changed. He had some different ideas.
I don't know. He maybe just been so brilliant that it was just a lot of brilliant people.
Especially those that are so forward thinking, this is my idea.
That he was so forward thinking.
And in a way, you could kind of see ahead.
That if we kept going like this, this is where we would be.
And it would be that kind of visionary.
That could put a lot of strain on a person, especially when you're trying to get other folks to see what you see.
And we're too dumb. We're not that intelligent.
The general person can't understand it like that.
And what that does to a psyche and a mentality of a mental healthable person.
So he kind of started acting differently.
And so people started leaving.
The women started leaving.
And then when he came back, he had this charge that he left because of in the first place.
That he was supposed to shot the prostitute, I believe.
And so the witnesses, there was one witness finally, you know, finding they published her address and whatnot.
So he sends somebody out to kill this person.
And then he was putting all this stuff together in my head.
So he's not around to say that he didn't do it.
But this is me.
But when he got there, when they got there, the person, they went to the wrong house.
The lady's house, they went to, had a gun.
When they were trying to get in, she started shooting through the door.
So she shot some of the guys that came to get the witness.
And one of the guys died on the spot.
And I said, we all live communally.
So the guy that died had the same address on his license as where I was living.
So once they get his prints, then they get the search points and whatnot.
Then they come to that search, when they come to, you know, bust in my house.
Then they go search everything.
There were guns around almost all the houses.
They belonged to the party.
There wasn't our houses most of them.
And most of them were our, most of them had some stuff.
But they were only parts.
I think at that time, they felt that, you know, if the barrel was here,
and the trigger housing was here, and this was someplace else,
that, you know, they couldn't put any kind of charges on you.
Well, that wasn't true.
So when they went up to this closet,
did my kids play hide and seek in?
I didn't know what it was.
They were just little suitcases, police cases in there.
They came and they just started cartoning out all kind of stuff.
I'm like, oh my goodness, I'm going to jail.
I'm going to jail.
But it was a, it was an eye-opening time.
It really was, you know, that he would order something like that, you know,
to save himself when I just stayed in Cuba.
And so, you know, that was, you know, things just started spiraling after that.
And then people started leaving more.
And I went to jail, and then I got kicked out.
Because now, QE had to fight this case.
So why spend the resources to fight my case?
If he's going to need it, resources to fight his case.
So I was on my own.
You kicked your other party?
Yeah.
But what I had on my back.
So I left and I fought my case for a year.
And I ended up getting sentenced to two years in California State Prison.
Which I did 12 or 13 months.
And then I went to work for a low.
And while I worked for a low,
there was this Jewish woman there to work with parolees.
But while I was in prison, that was an interesting experience, too.
I never, I didn't even have traffic tickets on my records, you know.
I went, do not pass, go, go.
Do not collect $200, go directly.
Because I was at the time when it was not used to go and go to jail,
but have a gun, go to jail.
You know how the wind shift back and forth.
And it was right during that time.
Have a gun, go to jail.
My fingerprints weren't on anything.
You know.
And so there were a couple of people in the jewelry.
We got a chance to pull them afterwards.
And a couple of them said that they really didn't believe that I had any control over it.
But that's what it would take for you to be guilty to have knowledge, possession, and control.
So it was my house.
The utilities were in my name.
They said, I had control of it.
But anyway.
So where were you in cursory?
Here in Frontera, California, it's two for women.
But when I went there, I stayed in the reception center for three months.
Normally they transition you in, do your physical, psych, and you're out two or three weeks.
But they were watching me making sure that I wasn't going to inside a riot or something.
Format revolution.
Yes, yes, they should know that I was so far.
At that point in my life, I was like, that was the last thing I was thinking about.
And so when I finally moved me to the main campus, they put me in a cell by myself because they didn't want me in.
And that was right fine with me because there was some folks up there whether she would want to sell with.
I mean, because they were always doing things they would be going to jail in jail for the activities in there.
Nothing political, brewing hooch and doing whatever other kinds of things that they get you locked up while you're already locked up.
So, sitting worked circulate that you were a black man there and what did that, what kind of response did they get from?
I got a lot of respect from everybody.
The administration were giving me a hard time initially.
But eventually I became secretary for the Women's Advisory Council.
And I had a pass, I could go in and out administration.
I had a typewriter in my room.
I went in and wrote in college class.
I got my AA degree while I was there.
I transferred my credits from Berkeley and in Cal State LA and got an AA and took a couple other classes.
So, when I got out at work study, this woman sent me on interviews and I had four interviews and I was off of jobs by three people.
So, I went back to school, got my bachelor's in healthcare administration and kept working and then went back to the state and school and got a master's in health administration, mostly in administering substance abuse programs.
And then at the age of 55 I went back to school and got a marriage of family therapy and taking the masters.
So, you know, I just kept moving and didn't look back.
I mean, it was something being in the party, I wouldn't have the skills to do the things that I've done since if I hadn't been there.
That was just really unfortunate event that happened and that I had to deal with and be away from my family for that amount of time.
But, you know, it's over and you chalk it up to experience and just keep moving forward.
You're saying?
Yeah, I didn't know that I'd ever put that on film.
I wanted to ask about the other nonprofits, especially shields for families, but I don't know if that was first in the progression.
No, well, I worked with some other nonprofits here in Los Angeles.
But in 1990, I was working for the county alcohol and drug program.
I stayed with them for about a year and a half.
I waited too long to become a government employee.
I couldn't go through the just pretending to work.
I mean, I've talked about my work and I couldn't come into work and push your paper from this side of the desk to the other side for the evening tomorrow.
I'll come in and move it over here and act like I'm doing something.
So, my supervisor and I were, we'd be writing grants.
We'd be there late at night, we'd come in on weekends and we had over $20 million of funding to come in to support substance abuse programs.
Specifically, women's programs for women who had substance abuse problems and their children were born prenatally exposed to drugs.
We were there when Diane Watson introduced a bill into the state legislature asking to have funds set aside for the before county hospitals in Los Angeles to address that issue.
Because at Martin Luther King Jr.-Charles R. Charles R. Drew Medical Center, over 1,200 children and year were being born prenatally exposed to drugs, primarily crack.
So, the bill passed, became law.
So, the doctor who was a neonatologist at King called us at the county,
she had worked with us on the proposal and said, you know, I know how to treat the children, but I don't know how to run a drug abuse program.
You guys can have to come out and run it.
So, my boss and I left the county, came out and started running the program.
Initially, it was under the auspices of a true medical school.
But after about a year or so, we formed our own 501(c)(3)(3) and started getting our monies directly.
We started with a grant of about a half million dollars a year, 14 employees.
And after 24 years, when I retired, we had 350 employees in about 25 million dollars in funding.
You tell us about the first.
28 or 29 programs.
You tell us about the first building, in quotes.
The first building.
We were given an old trailer that it was set on the land of Charles R. Charles R. Charles R. Drew University of Medicine and Science, but the trailer belonged to Martin Luther Martin Luther King Jr.-Charles R. Charles R. Drew Medical Center, County Hospital.
In South Central, that was built by the riots, as a direct result of that.
But the building was so old and dilapidated, it should have been condemned.
It had been sitting in for a long time, and you just had to watch where you stepped.
Certain places, your foot, my God, go through to the bottom.
But we pieced it together and made it work.
So we ran our program out of there for a while, and we're able to get funding from the Department of Health Services to help us renovate that trailer and to build us another one so that we could expand.
So we just started with a one program for women who had drug abuse problems, who had children, 0 to 5.
And they came into the program when they were pregnant or right after they had a baby that was tested positive for drugs.
And we worked with them on the substance abuse issues.
Then we started seeing that they were coming in close to homeless or homeless.
So we went out and found some apartments, got some money from HUD, put together some packaging and bought two 18-unit apartment complexes that we could house some of the women in.
And they just kept coming in homeless.
And so we found another project in Compton, 86-unit.
So we bought that so that we could house more.
And more of them were coming in with mental health issues.
So we got a psychiatrist to come and work with us.
So we started looking at the behavioral health, the other behavioral health concerns.
We were able to get funding from the Department of Mental Health to help with that.
And that more funding from the Department of Substance Abuse, where we used to work.
And they were one of our main funders at the time.
And it still are.
Started with vocational services because most of the women maybe had a 4 to 6 great education or reading level.
So all these are so related.
There are similar programs that we had in the party.
So the three.
And what I did at SHIELD was I was the health officer for the longest.
We had a major AIDS grant and I was the primary person working on that.
So as well as the financial piece, I became the chief operating officer.
So I had some programmatic responsibilities from time to time.
But yes, the programs that were that and still are run out of SHIELDs.
They kind of mirror, kind of work that I did when I was in the party.
So I can't ever regret what I did.
Because it's at the stage and helped me to build the skills to do what I needed to do when I came back here.
And you worked through all these major epidemics.
Drug epidemic, AIDS, crack, gang, but yeah.
Yeah.
And SHIELDs was very instrumental because it's in what?
We started right there on 120th in Compton.
It now has probably 17, 18 sites.
And we're in about 20 schools doing mental health services as well.
So we're all over the South Central, Linwood Watts, Willoughbrook area.
And even down that far from here, we have a resource center.
Yeah, I've watched, I've seen a lot of things come and go.
And I've seen so much cyclical stuff happening.
Now with Affordable Care Act 2010, which I'm really happy past.
We're having some unexpected consequences.
As a result of it, there's still a lot of bugs to be worked out.
But we went from, we're now going back to what they call a medical model where
they want substance abuse services to be treated in the medical facility.
And we thought to change that back in the 80s and 90s
and we're able to have substance abuse look at differently.
Because there are some aspects that are a lot different.
That's not to say that it couldn't be treated.
And it's good to have integrated care.
It's just really concerned that they're now going to be excluding the people
that have done this treatment services for so long and upping the requirements for them to have degrees.
And a lot of these folks are recovering people who have, you know,
they've learned certain sets of skills.
And we just don't know what's going to happen with that.
Now.
Is it difficult when you see things cycle back?
Oh, it is.
I think about Mother May I, you know, you take two baby steps forward and ten giant steps backwards.
And you think, you know, I did all this.
I stayed up all those long hours for what?
Sometimes you wonder, you know, how could we have let it roll back like this again?
But I think we'll work out that medical piece as long as Donald Trump.
We'll be able to work through some of those things.
But I've gone, I've retired from SHIELDs, but I was asked to become part of community faculty at Charles R. Charles R. Charles R. Drew University of Medicine and Science.
Which is a different type of track of instructors.
There are people like me who have been working in the community with nonprofits,
running nonprofits for years and years.
And what we are commissioned to do is to work with the medical students, nursing students,
MPH students, to help them to understand the community better,
help them to understand better the social determinants of health.
What a phenomenal program.
Yes.
Are there others in the country doing this?
No, the video only one.
So, you know, because we think it's so important that they need to learn those skills.
It's so unfair to send the students out into the community to work in.
Especially ones that aren't from this community, they don't know.
They don't know that just because you give this person a prescription doesn't mean they're going to take it.
First of all, it doesn't mean that they're going to buy it because they may not have the money.
They may not trust you because they keep thinking about the research
and all that kind of stuff that's happened with people of color over the years.
So, they don't trust the medical system or they can't read what you just written and given to them.
It's just all kinds of dynamics.
And then you go home with the family dynamics and they say,
you know, you don't take that.
You take these herbs and mix it with this bark and do that.
You don't take that medicine.
So, it's all these other social determinants of health that, you know,
the students have to be trained on.
And even the existing, the current professors, it's a hard thing because a lot of the old guys,
they're not trying to change what they're thinking.
So, when you go and try to teach the students and they get in the classroom and they tell them what they've always told them.
And I keep saying we got to think of a different way to do something because obviously what we're doing is not working
because my people still die in the illness.
Something's not working somewhere so we need to tweak this a little bit.
But to turn to those who've actually been working in the trenches,
there's so much sense.
Yeah, so it's been interesting and I've been able to
follow us under the auspices of University of California, Los Angeles.
So, I work with some doctors and nurses there, especially in the research department.
And I've been working on some of the committees to look at diversity in the medical education curriculum.
And how do we train the physicians and how do we train the existing instructors?
How do we train the students about some of these concepts that, you know,
do you think that they need to know about working in our communities?
So, that's what you're doing now?
Yeah, I do that a little bit.
Yeah, so don't tell them some advice we've got for diabetes and stroke prevention and things like that.
But more health-related things now.
When I heard you retire, I didn't think that that would last long.
I guess a how do you retire from a passion?
I keep trying, you know, I'm learning to say no more.
I haven't learned to say no all the time yet, but I'm going to get there one day.
Coming back to the Panthers for a moment, what are your thoughts about how the Panthers are remembered or thought of?
You know, and this is, again, like working with kids and what people know.
I'm curious what your thoughts are on.
Things that I think that I'd like to see them.
Yeah, you know, or ways in which you think, you know, maybe the Panthers are misremembered or misrepresented,
or what you would like kids to know.
Okay.
Well, the whole piece about the guns and self-defense, I mean, that that, that's important.
I mean, because if you're dead, all the rest of this doesn't count.
There's no need to look at anything else.
So we have to make sure that we're safe first.
But that wasn't the hype.
That wasn't the ultimate of what the party was about.
We had a plethora of survival programs.
And we called it survival-pending revolution because we knew it would be a long protracted struggle
before we got to see any of the changes made that we knew needed to occur in order for us to,
to our people to start living a better life.
And when I say our people, I'm talking about all poor and oppressed people in this country and the world,
because the United States, you know, they had their tentacles all over the place.
But I'd like to know that the party was interested in children and adults
in every facet of our lives to make sure that we had the best life possible.
And we did what we could to make that happen for as long as we could do it.
So anything that I didn't ask that I should have asked?
I don't think so.
And just my children, you know, it's interesting that children have a different take on things.
And my daughter, she's right out there, she's an educator, but she's really for making sure that the children of color get what they need
and runs into a lot of obstacles in the educational systems because of that.
But what she remembers most about the party was that the camaraderie,
and she still has friends that she still collaborates with.
And when she left, she was only about, maybe she was six or seven years old.
But she grew up in it, yeah.
And she still in touch with those people and those are like lifelong friends forever.
But yeah, I just like the young people to know that, you know,
I like for them not to make some of the mistakes that we made.
To be open to hear our stories, to see where we step in the ditch so that they don't have to step in that same ditch,
they can move around it and go higher and farther than we did.
I just think of one thing I wanted to ask you, we talked a little bit before we started the camera about working with other like-minded organizations,
especially the Brown Berets + Brown Berets + Pinto Union. Could you talk a little bit about what those kind of coalition buildings are?
Yes, I can remember working in some of their rallies and just coalescing with them in activities and events that they were having.
And having similar ideologies and I can remember some of our party members going out working with César Chávez and the farm workers.
And just forming coalitions with, you know, who was ever open to talk about, let's make some changes in this country because we know if we can make them here,
hopefully they don't be able to extend out through the rest of the world where people are oppressed like they are here.
So like I said, I was mostly focused on the health piece, I didn't get a chance to be out more.
And at that time more people in the top leadership were doing that. I didn't really become in the party's executive committee until I became the finance minister in Oakland.
So a lot had happened before I got to that point.
Yeah, but there was a lot of coalescing going on with the great panthers and with the seniors in the universities.
And anti-war movement, the women's movement? Yes, yes, all of those.
Fellas, any questions?
No, I just want to talk about that. Coaching up in water?
Happy sale. I guess I didn't have one question.
You mentioned talking to young people saying once you could tell them that might be mystified some of the sort of unfortunate and prelicious method of panthers.
In your own mind, what, looking back on it for years ago, you walked in that door at the time of the party?
Did you ever see that trajectory taking you to where it was now?
I did not. I did not see myself as a visionary. I guess I still don't make in summary guards that I might be.
But I was more a day-to-day grinder, get the work done, make sure the books are okay, make sure the hell is okay.
I guess maybe is it my left side of my brain is just totally taxed and I haven't really exercised to write very much.
I'm trying to do more of that now and stepping out and thinking about different things that might occur.
But I never felt like I really had the time to allow myself to let my mind go there.
It was like, okay, here I am today. And then you go three or four years and you look like you say, my goodness, how did I get here?
I didn't expect to be at this point.
A lot of times you didn't even know you were going to be alive the next year.
So that kept a lot of us, I think, from thinking ahead like that.
But to be thinking that I would come out of the party, especially after being in prison and being able to keep moving ahead and moving up and still being able to do the same types of work on a broader scale.
As I came back to this community, it's just not something that everyone crossed my mind.
But I'm glad that I had that experience and skills to be able to come and do that.
But we're grateful to you for the work that you've done and for sharing your story today.
Thank you for involving me.
Absolutely. Thank you.
Okay.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.